vous voulez changer votre smartphone
vous voulez un smartphone de samsung
parce que vous aimez la marque parce que
vous êtes des samsung parce que vous
savez que leurs écrans sont toujours de
très bonne qualité mais vous vous dites
quel smartphone de samsung ht en 2020 et
je vous comprends pas ce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya une gamme qui est quand même
extrêmement large entre le très haut de
gamme entre le milieu de gamme entre
l'entrée de gamme ont trop les
smartphones qui se plie arrive un moment
où on ne sait plus quel smartphone
choisir et on ne sait plus quelle
direction prendre heureusement monsieur
greu est là pour vous aider
je vais donc vous aider à savoir quel
smartphone samsung ht en 2020 alors il
ya déjà beaucoup de smartphones qui sont
sortis en 2020 de samsung certains
sortiront cette année encore notamment
au niveau de la gamme note 20 alors à
laquelle je tourne ses smartphones sont
pas sortis ce que donc pas tout de suite
vous guider dessus on va donc se
concentrer sur les produits que je
connais les produits que j'ai testé des
produits de pouvoir vous recommander
alors rassurez vous j'ai quasiment
tester tous les produits de samsung
existant aujourd'hui donc j'ai tous les
arguments pour venir vous conseiller et
vous guider au mieux pour savoir quel
smartphone de samsung ht en 2020 on va
tout de suite commencer par les
smartphones qui se plie vous avez eu en
le samsung galaxy fold où vous alliez
ouvrir la surface de votre smartphone
pour transformer votre smartphone en une
petite tablette
à la différence des bus 2020 samsung a
présenté le galaxy z flip c'est un
smartphone qui se plie on vient de
réduire l'encombrement on est ici sont
des produits extrêmement dit chez le
galaxy folk ou 2020 euros le galaxy z
flip 1500 euros de toute façon si vous
allez choisir un smartphone pliable vous
irez selon la région du coeur est ce que
vous voulez agrandir la surface où est
ce que voulait la rendre plus petit il y
avoir un smartphone plus compagne là
dessus c'est à vous de faire votre choix
et je suis pas sûr vous apporter de
grands éclaircissements on arrive dans
le coeur du problème
en commençant par le très haut de gamme
vous voulez ce que samsung fait mieux
vous voulez un excellent smartphone vous
voulez le meilleur de samsung que ce
soit au niveau de l'écran au niveau de
la photo mais vous ne savez pas
réellement lequel prendre cette année
samsung a sorti pas moins de trois
modèles s20 s20 plus s20 ultra en plus
le s20 et le s20 plus ont une
déclinaison chacun kadjé 5g donc vous
avez choix entre cinq modèles en 2020 et
en 2019 vous avez le choix entre le s10
le s10 plus il ya le s10 light qui
arrivait
il y avait aussi le s10 eux au bout d'un
moment cette vie un petit peu difficile
de faire son choix heureusement rassurez
vous je vous file un coup de main je
vais vous expliquer avec très simple
elle la question se situe toujours au
niveau du budget c'est la question du
budget n'est pas très importante pour
vous et que vous avez les moyens vous
voulez ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui chez samsung
je vous invite à aller sur le galaxy s
20 ultras qui est vitrine pour samsung
vous avez un écran incroyable très bel
appareil photo vous avez de la 5g vous
avez un très beau smartphone donc si
vous voulez ce qui se fait de mieux chez
samsung et que vous êtes prêts à mettre
la modique somme de 1000 359 euros et
bien je peux que vous recommander
d'aller voir ce smartphone la cie
maintenant ce smartphone ne vous tente
pas vous avez le choix entre le s20 et
le s20 puce j'ai déjà publié une vidéo
faisant le comparatif pour savoir quel
smartphone choisir entre le s20 et le
s20 plus d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas
vu cette vidéo je vous invite à aller la
voir je crois que ça doit se situer
allez je veux dire par icitte le point
le plus important pour moi ici c'est le
format est ce que vous l'avez cran de
6,2 pouces ou un écran de 6,7 pouces
c'est vraiment là dessus qu'il faut
venir vous interroger une fête plus je
vous renvoie ma vidéo qui est très
complète et qui vous expliquera tout
donc si vous voulez un format compact
s20 si vous voulez un écran un peu plus
grand
elle devint plus vous avez aussi les
version 4g et 5g si vous voulez aller
sur la 5g et bien ça vous coûtera 100
euros de plus par smartphone si par
contre vous n'êtes pas convaincu tout de
suite par l'utilité de la saint jean
vous ruer sur la 4g et pour l'instant ça
ira très bien
maintenant se pose la question des
modèles de l'année dernière s10 s10 plus
s10e et rs 10 light qui est sorti pour
moi le point intéressant c'est le prix
puisque le s10 coûta actuellement 759
euros le s10 plus 859 euros
tous les deux sont en format 4 g ici pas
de 5 g et le s10e coûte 759 euros c'est
à dire que le s10 e&t le smartphone qui
avait l'essentiel du s10 mais qui
n'allait pas aussi loin que le s10
aujourd'hui le s10 ce couple même prix
que le s10 autant dire que le s10 e on
le prend et au lobby de la même manière
samsung a sorti un ace 10 l'elt il ya
très peu de temps qui coûte 699 euros
c'est-à-dire qu'il coûte 60 euros moins
cher que le s10 pourquoi aller se rend
s10 laguë coûte 60 euros moins cher
quand on arrive sur des tarifs qui sont
quand même relativement élevé à 559
euros sur le sbf positionnement
tarifaire du s10 light je vous conseille
pas d'aller su aller directement sur le
x10 ou sans laisse 10 plus une fois de
plus qui va compter
c'est le format est ce que vous voulez
un écran un peu plus grand un écran un
peu plus petit ça c'est à vous de voir
quant aux smartphones et suite s9 pour
moi ils sont trop anciens et si vous
souhaitez le garder un an deux ans vous
risquez d'avoir un smartphone qui
devient obsolète extrêmement rapidement
dont je voulais déconseille fortement on
arrive maintenant sur la gamme note vous
êtes toujours dans l'univers du flagship
chez samsung des produits de très bonne
qualité sauf que cette fois ci il ya un
accessoire et qui donne tout son intérêt
à cette gamme note c'est le s pen c'est
son style est donc si vous voulez un
smartphone avec un stylet vous en avez
réellement lusage ça vaut le coup
d'aller sur la gamme note dans le cas
contraire passez votre chemin
ici on a le choix entre trois produits
le galaxy note 10 le galaxy note 10 plus
et le galaxy no10 light et que je vous
ai notamment montré lorsque j'étais au
cs à las vegas la grosse différence que
vous allez avoir entre le galaxy note 10
et galaxy note 10 + vient se faire au
niveau du format au niveau de l'écran
puisque vous avez un écran de 6 3 pouces
sur le galaxy l'odyssée un écran de 6,8
pouces pour le galaxy note 10 plus une
différence au niveau de la batterie une
différence au niveau de la photo vous
avez une caméra tough sur le dise plus
mais dans l'ensemble ces deux produits
sont vraiment extrêmement similaires une
fois de plus le choix et se faire au
niveau du format est ce que vous voulez
quelque chose d'un peu plus grand ou
d'un peu plus petit ça dépend de la
taille de votre main ça dépend du
confort pour venir visionner ça c'est à
vous de choisir
mais c'était sans compter sur le galaxy
ne dise live présentée en début d'année
avec un écran de 6,7 pouces qui coûte la
modique somme de 609 euros
et si vous souhaitez acheter en 2020 un
galaxy note 10 il coûte 959 euros et le
galaxy note 10 plus 1109 euros autant
vous dire qu'à 609 euros
le galaxy note 10 light est vraiment une
bonne affaire vous avez de la
performance triple module photo 12
mégapixels est pas quelque chose qui est
très cohérent très bien et qui est
surtout un positionnement tarifaire qui
est vraiment bien donc si vous voulez un
smartphone avec un hespel et vous voulez
dépenser le moins d'argent possible le
note dislike vraiment est fait pour vous
si maintenant vous avez un budget un peu
plus large va falloir faire votre choix
entre le note 10 nov 10 plus et ça comme
vous voulez dit ça dépend évidemment du
format on arrive maintenant sur l'entrée
et le milieu de gamme en 2019 samsung a
changé la donne en supprimant la gabegie
et en regroupant tous sur la gamme art
vous avez donc une gamme à qui part du à
dix et qui va jusqu'aux à 90 le à 90 on
n'en parlera pas parce que en france il
n'est pas disponible
en tout cas pour le moment on va donc se
concentrer sur le a dit ça va monter
juste
à 80 en passant par de nouveaux modèles
que sont les à 51 et à 71
il ya une amélioration par rapport aux
modèles de l'année dernière et surtout
ils sont beaucoup plus intéressants je
donne les tarifs le à 71 coûte 399
tandis que le à 51 coûte 100 euros - 299
le à 70 contre 409
il est donc plus cher que lui à 71 et le
a50 coûte 349 euros il est donc 50 euros
plus cher que le à 51 donc le a50 et le
a70 sont de smartphone qu'on peut tout
de suite
supprimez not least le modèle le plus
cher et le à 80 à 659 euros et il faut
noter que aussi une différence de 100
euros entre le galaxy à 80 et le galaxy
s 10 100 euros c'est une somme
mais quitte à choisir un smartphone que
vous allez garder minimum deux ans
autant partir tout de suite sur ce qui
se fait de mieux donc pour moi le à 80
va disparaître au profit du galaxy s 10
il nous reste donc le à 10 vraiment
l'entrée de gamme le à 20 heures que je
ne trouve pas extraordinaire je vous
l'avais d'ailleurs déjà dit lors de mon
test
et puis le à 40 le cac 40 qui coûte 259
euros c'est-à-dire qu'il coûte 40 euros
ou moins cher que le à 51 même si 40
euros reste quand même une somme je vous
invite quand même à venir les mettre en
plus pour partir sur ce qui sera le
mieux
mieux vaut avoir un à 51 de 2020 qu'un à
40 de 2019
donc si on résume vola les smartphones
que je viens vous conseiller cette année
chez samsung s 20s 20 plus le ultra
c'est tout autre chose mais il ira très
bien il faut mettre un peu plus d'argent
est-ce 10 16 10 + 9 10 note 10 plus il y
aura également le note 10 light qui sera
vraiment super compromis en termes de
tarifs et ensuite vous allez avoir le à
71 e à 51 et le dise vraiment pour
arriver chez samsung mais bon vous voyez
on va pas avoir grand chose en terme de
spec mais si vous voulez vraiment arrivé
chez samsung et que vous n'avez pas un
budget au delà de 159 euros
le à 10 pourquoi pas mais il n'a pas
fait redémarrer donc le à 51 on est à
299 euros
le à 71 on est à 399 euros
le no10 light 609 euros le 9 10 plus
1109 euros c'est tout de suite beaucoup
plus cher le note 10 959 euros
le s10 plus à 859 euros le s10 à 759
euros
le s20 plus à 1900 euros en 4g et le s20
anne
109 euros en 4g si vous posez la
question à faire votre choix entre à 71
et le à 51 le à 71 sera plus performant
vous avez un seul dragon 730 qui tombera
beaucoup mieux que les dinos 9611 que
vous y retrouver sur le à 51% euros de
plus vous aurez un capteur de 64
mégapixels au lieu d'un 48 mégapixels
vous aura smartphones plus performant
vous aurez une batterie un peu plus
grosse pour vous le fait d'avoir plus de
performances un meilleur appareil photo
et une meilleure autonomie
valls en europe + oui ou non ça c'est à
vous de trancher la différence vous
allez avoir entre le note 10 note 10
plus le s10 le s10 plus et le s20 le lez
le plus ce sont des différences qui se
calcule au niveau du fort ma la
différence de formats coûte 100 euros
sauf au niveau de la gamme note elle
coûte 150 euros plus mais pour moi le
vrai bon plan ici ça peut être le no10
leitza c'est à vous de voir donc voyez
les vrais bons plans chez samsung pour
moi ils seront sur ses smartphones là
c'est toujours une question de budget
c'est aussi bien souvent une question de
format et dans tous les cas une question
d' usage chez samsung les dalles sont
toujours très bien maîtrisée donc pour
tout ce qui va être multimédia c'est à
dire film ses rimes et flix youtube et
compagnie pour des réseaux sociaux dans
tous les cas ces smartphones vous enlève
le à 10 mai tous les autres font très
bien la faire si vous voulez quelque
chose de très performant ou à les joies
des jeux il faut aller sur les
smartphones les plus haut de gamme pour
avoir le maximum de performance après
pour faire tourner beaucoup de jeu de
dupes les stores et bien je dirais que
sur l'ensemble des smartphones vous
aurez de quoi faire si vous voulez
vraiment de très belles photos
il faut venir monter en gamme néanmoins
le à 71 et le à 51 feront aussi très
bien le tas sans capteur principal
voilà donc ma sélection samsung à un
instant t en 2020 je peux pas tenir
compte des smartphones qui sont pas
encore sorti que je ne connaîtrais pas
et qui potentiellement vont arriver dans
le reste de l'année 2020 mais voyez sur
cette photo prise à un instant t ses
smartphones là sont bien là ce que je
propose ce sont les tarifs 9 vous pouvez
aussi les trouver en reconditionnés je
vous mets des liens en bas dans la
description aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil comme ça vous trouverez ce qui se
fait de mieux au meilleur prix a vous de
me dire maintenant vous ce que vous en
pensez
quel smartphone samsung vous avez eu
qu'un smartphone samsung vous pensez
avoir fait est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ma sélection ou est-ce que vous
verriez à nos smartphones dans cette
liste qu'il faudrait absolument rajouter
à vous de me dire ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain pour continuer à parler tech
avec vous des bisous et à demain
ciao
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]